لا هجمات روسيه بالمسيرات على اوكرانيا
منذ 17 من نوفمبر جيري هذا ما كشفت عنه
الاستخبارات البريطانيه مضيفه انه من
المحتمل نفاذ مخزون روسيا من الطائرات
المسيره ايرانيه الصنع وستسعى على الارجح
للحصول على المزيد خلال الفتره المقبله
وفيما بدا كانه تبادل الادوار اتخذ الجيش
الاوكراني هذه المره وضعيه المهاجم
بالمسيرات واين على شبه جزيره القرم التي
اعلن حاكمها الروسي اسقاط عده مسيرات
اوكرانيا وفي وقت يتوقع فيه يتوقع ان يكون
الشتاء قاسيا على اوكرانيا اعلانات منظمه
الصحه العالميه عن ان مئات المستشفيات
ومشات الرعايه الصحيه في اوكرانيا تفتقر
الى الوقود والماء والكهرباء لتلبيه
الاحتياجات الاساسيه للافراد
[موسيقى]